it anyway first quasi-cuateng who has  been confirmed as chancellor james  cleverley the country's new foreign  secretary suella bravaman home secretary  ben wallace remains in place defense  secretary well to raise coffee her great  ally appointed the new deputy prime  minister and health secretary  jacob rees-mogg is the new business  secretary delighted to be so we caught  words with him earlier brandon lewis has  been named justice secretary well nadim  zahawi who began the day as chancellor  is now a cabinet office minister  wendy morton has been named chief whip  penny mordent another one of those who  stood uh in this election the leader of  the house of commons came kemi baidnot  yet another contender for the role  appointed international trade secretary  kitten malthouse we saw him a short time  ago is the new education secretary